[Music]
so it's the early 1920s you're Ernest
Oppenheimer and you have a monopoly over
all the diamond mines in South Africa
the biggest diamond producer in the
world at the time and you thought you
and your company De Beers were on top of
the world
diamonds make for great jewelry that the
world is willing to pay top dollar for
they have industrial uses that no other
materials can really replace and you
control a main area of the world where
90% of diamonds are coming from the best
can top $100,000 a carat but you run
into a problem up until then when
diamonds were discovered in South Africa
the only places where there were mined
were India and Brazil which made
everyone think diamonds are pretty rare
making them very valuable much like how
gold is valuable but becoming more and
more apparent that diamonds aren't
really as rare as we once thought
diamonds were popping up all over Africa
at your mind alone you're digging up so
many diamonds that if you were to put
all of them on the market it would
absolutely crush your prices in fact
diamonds can exist wherever there's
carbon which is pretty much everywhere
in the world so the economics of
diamonds are looking pretty bleak but
you're a very clever businessman so
you're not willing to throw in the towel
quite yet you need to shift your
business from trying to dig as many
diamonds out of the ground as possible
to doing everything in your power to
control how many diamonds come out of
the ground while simultaneously keeping
the public completely unaware of how
worthless this mineral they're paying
top dollar for really is the diamond
market is dependent for its smooth
function on the maintenance of the
illusion in the minds of the general
public that the diamond is a rare and
valuable stone you need to turn your
modest diamond operation into the most
successful monopoly cartels the world
has ever seen
[Music]
nobody's aware that diamonds and all the
associations we have with diamonds is a
product of a marketing strategy so to
put it bluntly we were a better ish
group for a commodity which sells at
thousands of dollars a carat the supply
it seems truly staggering if you
measured in terms of how all the myths
associated with this advertising
campaign have been deeply inculcated in
people its reach deeply into the popular
imagination this is probably the most
successful campaign in history when you
hear the word cartel the stereotypical
violent drug cartel comes to mind but in
reality all a cartel really is is a
group of companies coming together to
fix the price of a product so that all
the cartel members get their fair share
of the profits kind of like how the
major oil countries come together as the
cartel OPEC to fix the price of crude
oil that's what we have to do here the
more diamonds on display shells at
jewelry stores the lower the price
people will pay for them but if all the
diamond suppliers came under your
control you can dictate how many
diamonds go on to the market and thus
how much money consumers pay for them
the first step to controlling the supply
is a start at the source buy up all
these wannabe diamond miners popping up
all over Africa once these pesky locos
catch on to how profitable the diamond
trade is they'll start trading diamonds
on their own and smuggling to bypass you
so do whatever is necessary to crush
them claim that these criminals are
unlicensed that they're black-market
dealers since Africa can be pretty
lawless you can just hire a private
detectives to get Intel out of these
criminals about their illegal trade of
kidnapping interrogations beatings it's
all fair game
[Music]
I took them as prisoners there was
beatings
there was punishments without food we
did everything from them now that you
have the start of the supply chain under
your grip it's time to move on to the
next level
the merchants once the diamonds are dug
from the ground they're so to merchants
who the ones that actually cut them into
the jewelry that is eventually sold to
the public
things determine the price or value of
diamond jewelry color cut clarity and of
course weight measured in carats these
are the diamonds that the public will
get their hands on so making sure the
merchants are obedient we're cartel
intentions it's more important than ever
since you control 90% of the world's
diamond output merchants who want to buy
raw diamonds can really only go to you
that means you have complete control
over who has the privilege of buying
from you how many diamonds they get and
the size and the quality of the diamonds
they get whatever you give them don't
just have to suck it up and say thank
you since you're a monopoly you can't
legally operate in the US so set up shop
in London where you'll distribute your
raw diamonds to merchants to create an
aura of exclusivity create a club of
only 200 merchants that get to buy
directly from you and call them site
holders these site holders are the bread
and butter of how you'll control the
market these 200 will buy from you and
the rest of the world has to buy from
these 200 every five weeks they'll come
to you our London HQ and request a grade
of diamonds they need but remember
you're in control here so sift is giving
them exactly what they need willy nilly
you look at the market and determine
what grade of diamonds are in short
supply and what aren't to keep prices
high only give site holders what's in
short supply and withholds from them
what's in high supply this is very
interesting
these are greens that come from Botswana
and this is a regular cotton dried bread
and butter item
these are priced in such a way that
there's very little remember these
merchants have no one else to go to so
by determining what diamonds they get
you control the Popish strings that make
or break their business if they're
acting as obedient members of the cartel
reward them with better and more
diamonds if they're not punished them
with less economical diamonds to make
them fall back into line I've been very
angry and cost a lot and is very upset
but that's how the cookie crumbles I
know I have no options
[Music]
fast forward to the 1930s and you're
making more money than ever but the
people in your biggest potential market
the us just don't really care about
diamonds all that much unlike today and
your sales were pretty small
I bumped those numbers out those are
rookie numbers in this racket you need
to somehow create that the man in
American consumers you need to make
Americans believe that diamonds are
priceless but here's the problem at the
end of the day jewelry is just let
jewelry ain't nice to have a luxury that
only people were extra money lying
around can afford so if you want to make
some real money you need to make
diamonds be perceived as something more
than just jewelry to symbolize something
so evergreen that no matter how the
economy was doing no matter how rich or
poor a person was people would always
need diamonds almost as much as they
need something like water enter love
everyone needs love he'll men are
notorious for turning their worlds
completely upside down to earn the love
of a woman so if you can get diamonds to
represent love in the eyes of the
populace everything will fall into place
with plenty of money to follow no matter
how poor a man is if you can get him to
believe that the ultimate gesture of
love a man can give a woman is by buying
her the biggest diamond he can get hands
on he'll make it happen so here's what
you do you know how easily influenced
people are by the movie stars they look
up to they're the trendsetters so you
open up an office in Hollywood to start
making some influential friends you give
out your most valuable diamonds to
producers in exchange for a private
placement in their films on some very
strict grounds which was a very
innovative thing at the time the man in
the movie had to surprise the love of
his life with diamonds as the ultimate
sign of commitment you know
I want you to mind your love with me too
aren't you
well if I'm not and I'm afraid I don't
know what love is
there's your engagement present this
will start to subconsciously associate
diamonds as a symbol of love in the eyes
of the populace when top movie stars are
out and about you make sure that they're
never seen in public without draping
them in their De Beers diamonds this is
in fact the essence of propaganda
getting influencers people that the
general public look up to to promote the
ideas you want the populace to believe
in and it worked
diamonds became the quintessential
symbol of love and Americans just
couldn't get enough of it or could they
even though you're making money hand
over fist if people start to sell their
secondhand diamonds onto the use market
this new source of supply will crush
your demand ruining your entire scheme
so much like the African diamond mines
and the merchants you've got to get this
piece of the supply chain under your
control you've convinced people that
diamonds are the ultimate symbol of love
but if you don't somehow convince people
that they should never sell their
diamonds after they buy them your
business is gonna hit a glass ceiling so
you create the infamous diamonds are
forever campaign in hopes that people
will hold their diamonds forever it is
precious
and it's only promise is forever that a
man should buy a diamond for every
romantic milestone not to get rid of
your diamond is tantamount to throwing
away your love for your significant
other into the trash two months salary
lasts forever not to buy a used diamond
is to buy the tainted use love of the
previous owner and yet again your genius
marketing tactics worked diamonds sell
for a fraction of the price on the used
market beliefs like diamonds are a
girl's best friend diamonds are forever
that you can only truly propose to
someone with a diamond ring is so
ingrained in our culture that people
just assume that this is how it's always
been
while little do they know that their
gravitation towards diamonds is the
result of history's greatest marketing
campaign and you want to know what the
best part is it's that even if all your
genius marketing tactics get exposed
even if the public becomes well aware
that their attraction towards diamonds
is completely artificial they'll still
buy them like all deception the
perceived plays a part in the deception
as well as the deceiver it's not a one
once you have the supply chain and the
need for diamonds covered you're gonna
be raking in massive amounts of money
which is gonna attract the wrong
attention small-time leeches will always
be trying to take a piece of your pie so
you need to maintain ruthless control do
whatever it takes to keep diamond
smuggling to a minimum since diamonds
can be found all over the world
ambitious prospectors will eventually
come across some and open up some new
mines which is exactly what happened in
the 50s in Siberia and again in the late
70s in Australia dealing with the
Soviets was pretty simple with you just
need some good old-fashioned
under-the-table dealings with them to
funnel their diamonds through your
London HQ Australia was more of a
challenge however being that there of
modern democratic society but with some
price threats here some lobbying and
binding of company stocks there sprinkle
on a little PR and give the Australians
their own unique diamonds sell and boom
the Australian diamond supply is flowing
straight through London if somebody were
to try to go around the cartel the
concern that they would have to have is
how long it would lie the more diamonds
you controlled the more diamond cutters
you're gonna need so get some cheap
labor in India where children will work
for four cents per diamond for 12 hours
per day this is called more flesh less
cash and as long as you're able to
maintain this ruthless control you can
sit back relax and enjoy the fruits of
one of the most lucrative monopoly
cartels history has ever seen
[Music]
fast forward to today and the beers has
largely fallen out of favor why they
lost control of their supply chain in an
ever-changing world more and more
country started discovering their own
diamond reserves and after decades of
putting up with the cartel some
countries like Russia Canada and
Australia finally thought that they had
enough and refused to corroborate with
them lab-grown
artificial diamonds also became a thing
and they were found to be nearly
identical than natural forming ones and
what all these forces combined and many
others it forced the beers to switch
from completely controlling supply to
promoting their own brand of diamonds
and retail source which is still going
strong to this day but it's a far cry
from the stranglehold they had on the
industry just a few decades ago so
what's the lesson from this lose control
of your supply chain and you lose your
monopoly
[Music]
welcome to the watch little End Club if
you're new this channel I make video
essays just like this one every single
week on the most provocative stuff in
the world business so consider
subscribing with the red button below
it's free and remember you can always
disliked and unsub whenever you want
feeling lonely in quarantine or you feel
lonely with life in general well we just
launched our free community discord
server last week it's been growing
pretty quickly and people have a pretty
good time in there so you can interact
with some pretty cool people that are
also interested in business and
entrepreneurship and all that good stuff
for free with the link below guys we
just passed a hundred thousand
subscribers and I cannot tell you guys
how long I have been waiting for this it
has been years I'm a very happy man and
it's kind of hard to express how
grateful I am that you guys are a part
of this whether you recently discovered
this channel or you've been around since
the very beginning we just had like a
few hundreds of survivors and we were
just trying to get by I don't talk about
this too much but the current goal of
this channel right now is just to make
the world a little bit more curious the
way I like to think about it is this
channel acting as the gateway drug into
curiosity because the way I think of it
is that every discovery every invention
every successful business anything like
that every ounce of human progress has
all started with someone being curious
enough to pursue that adventure and even
though our generation has access to more
information than all of our ancestors
combined it just doesn't really seem
like people really take advantage of it
and
is what we are trying to change here
with this channel and by you subscribing
to it you re part of it and I cannot
thank you enough I'm very grateful for
you guys but yeah that's gonna wrap it
up for this video you guys thank you so
much for watching I probably set that
like five times by now but seriously
thank you for a hundred thousand
subscribers you can follow me on
instagram at jake trend ah i oh you've
been awesome Ivan Jake I'll see you guys
in the next one
[Music]